los vínculos amorosos nos definen como
seres humanos
todos deberíamos poder nacer dentro de
vínculos amorosos pero no siempre ocurre
así por eso considero que debemos pensar
en el amor y en su contraparte aquellos
afectos agresivos que también habitan
dentro de todos nosotros y que son
aquellos que en una medida nos ayudan a
ser asertivos a poder poner límites a
decir no deja de hacerme esto me están
haciendo sentir mal a ayudarnos a saber
si algo está pasando si estamos en
peligro nos ponen alerta nos ayuda a
defendernos a saber si alguien está
haciendo abusivo con nosotros pero
también son aquellos aspectos que nos
ayudan entonces a entender a los demás
como también a dañar muchas veces las
relaciones cuando son afectos que no
están contenidos es la mezcla y de
mezcla de ambos afectos el amor y
también los aspectos agresivos lo que
hace que creamos relaciones que sean más
de seguridad y que nos brinden felicidad
y también relaciones que pueden ser muy
perjudiciales y destructivas
entendiendo entonces el desarrollo de
los afectos agresivos podemos saber que
muchas veces nos ayudan y otras veces
nos dañan dañan cuando se convierten en
agresión dañina destructiva cuando salen
de poder ser contenidos dentro de las
relaciones estos son aspectos que están
en nosotros desde que nacemos y se van
creando en nuestros vínculos primarios
desde que nacemos quienes nos cuidan
empiezan a tener un impacto en nuestras
relaciones y entonces al al poder
contener el amor a estos aspectos
agresivos entonces pues podemos tener
relaciones mucho más contenidas de
felicidad etc
hace muchos años el doctor sigmund freud
mientras estudiaba la mente y el
inconsciente del ser humano decía que
todos los encuentros del amor son
realmente reencuentros que quiso decir
con esto son reencuentros porque
aquellos nuestros cuidadores primarios
nuestros primeros amores pasan a ser los
referentes de amor y de relaciones en
nuestra mente y esto hace que nosotros
entonces busquemos luego relaciones que
nos recuerden aquellas que tuvimos
muchas veces como vínculos amorosos
otras veces como vínculos perjudiciales
entonces el impacto que tienen estas
primeras relaciones que llevamos desde
la cuna hasta más adelante están
presentes todo este tiempo y nos van
forjando nuestra personalidad y también
las relaciones que vayamos buscando más
adelante muchas personas dicen pero
porque siempre me toca gente así porque
será que a mí me tocan parejas que son
tan agresivas que son tan malvadas pero
no es que nos tocan así es que las
buscamos
conscientemente estas primeras
relaciones se han estudiado por muchos
años en dentro de la teoría
psicoanalítica con muchos autores como
volví winnicott el doctor pichón rivière
que dedicaron su tiempo y su vida a
estudiar estas primeras relaciones y el
impacto que tenían en el desarrollo del
ser humano autores como otros que han
ver hoy día muy contemporáneo lo que
estudian es también como estas primeras
relaciones tienen el impacto en las
relaciones de pareja y como esta mezcla
y de mezcla de los aspectos que estamos
hablando afectos primarios
ayudan entonces a tener mejores
relaciones o no
entonces pensemos que la fuerza
contenedora primordial es el amor
es el amor el que cuando la madre por
ejemplo recibe a su hijo y el padre
llaman al hijo a la vida es el que le
enseña el mundo el que lo hace querer
vivir dentro del mundo que le tocó el
que le enseña quién es él le da un
mensaje de bienvenida que lo ayuda
entonces a saber cómo es él y qué es lo
que se espera de él en el mundo los
vínculos
y nacionales se dan desde el inicio
pueden haber también reediciones porque
a medida que vamos creando nuevas
relaciones
también se pueden ir reeditando tenemos
nuevas oportunidades y esto qué quiere
decir que muchas veces pueden ocurrir o
sea que uno continúa vínculos amorosos
que luego también pueden ir cambiando o
por ejemplo un niño que ha tenido
vínculos donde han sido más agresivos
por ejemplo pero también has recibido
amor y más adelante tiene una pareja que
maneja muy bien la agresión y lo ayuda
también a él a contenerlo y pueden hacer
relaciones más sanas estaban reeditando
y creando nuevos estilos de relación
también
qué pasa entonces cuando el odio es
mayor que el amor
y grave no es triste cuando el odio es
mayor que el amor el niño se siente
rechazado por sus padres un bebé que
nace en una pareja donde es esperado
donde es deseado donde es este estado en
la mente de sus padres desde antes de
nacer versus un niño que se siente
rechazado porque llegan un momento de la
vida de los padres donde no es deseado
va a tener un comienzo de vida
totalmente diferente esto puede producir
marcas en el niño para siempre nosotros
hemos estudiado mucho el embarazo
adolescente aquí en panamá y vemos como
el bebé se hace una relación muy difícil
con la madre ya que el bebé representa
muchas veces el trauma vivido entonces
para la madre la joven madre es difícil
poder tener al bebé y no separarlo de
este trauma entonces otro otro indicio
que notamos es que se repite
transgeneracional mente esta misma
relación madre infante y en los padres
quedan muchas veces periferia
lo cual hace que no le brinde al bebé
otra oportunidad para tener otro estilo
de relación lo cual lo que ayudaría más
es que el padre esté más presente para
poder brindarle a la madre otro tipo de
relación con su bebé
el amor frustrado provoca agresión esto
se ve mucho en las parejas cuando un
miembro de la pareja no se siente amado
suficiente por su pareja le da mucha
rabia le provoca agresión estos van
distintos grados o sea cuando el vínculo
se hace demasiado agresivo entonces se
produce en relaciones de agresión verbal
de agresión sexual que obviamente son
muy perjudiciales
y nosotros fallamos al hacer las cosas
en exceso un amor también demasiado
exagerado donde no hay límites crea
fusión de la madre con el bebé por
ejemplo es como si el bebé no sabe si lo
que está sintiendo viene de su madre o
es de él porque la madre se ha volcado
tanto sin darle ningún límite que no le
permite tener una mente propia poder
individualizarse y esto tampoco es sano
como haremos con los vínculos amorosos
de hoy
en los vínculos amorosos de hoy para
poder promover los tendríamos que pensar
varias cosas en un mundo donde estamos
cada vez más desconectados uno del otro
en un mundo donde estamos rodeados de
puras máquinas
en nuestro alrededor para hacer los
quehaceres diarios en un mundo donde
cada vez es más complicado encontrarse
es primordial el poder hacer un espacio
para crear esta cercanía emocional poder
promover estos vínculos es totalmente
primordial sobre todo hoy día pongámonos
a pensar por ejemplo ustedes están
tratando de resolver algo en un sistema
automatizado de respuesta y llaman con
su celular y le dice bueno marque el
número uno perfecto marcamos el número
uno
no pero ahora tienes que marcar el
número 2 marcamos el número 2 marque el
número 3 y cuando ya vamos por el número
4 empezamos a sentir una frustración
horrible y sentimos como que necesitamos
que salga un humano del otro lado del
celular y nos diga qué es lo que está
pasando cálmense no bueno a esa
frustración es a la que estamos
exponiendo todo el tiempo a los niños al
darle pantallas y celulares para que se
calmen lejos de calmarlos lo que estamos
haciendo es dándoles sobre estimulación
y mayor excitabilidad entonces esto no
calma al niño sino que corta el proceso
el niño llora por ejemplo porque se
siente mal en vez de llegar su mamá y
decirle hijo o su papá que te está
pasando te sientes mal ven acá este
cargo a ver que lo que tienes no no
tienes nada cálmate vamos a los padres
necesitan enseñarle a su hijo cómo
hacerlo para que él después lo pueda
hacer por sí mismo pero si el niño llora
y nosotros decimos coge tu pantalla que
yo voy a agarrar la mía necesito hablar
un momento aquí con otra amiga y todos
donde esta vista le estamos rechazando
no le estamos enseñando a regularse y
estos son estos temas que van creando
estos vacíos emocionales que estamos
hablando los vacíos emocionales como los
niños que estaba mencionando de nantes
cuando se han sentido muy frustrados y
no hay quien resuelva su frustración ese
vacío emocional es el que se va llenando
con cualquier otro estímulo externo
compras alcohol drogas algo que busca el
placer afuera que lo calme porque no
tiene la capacidad emocional para
calmarse por sí mismo en el mundo de hoy
si las pantallas son nuestros cuidadores
para los niños definitivamente no les
estamos ayudando a que puedan regular
sus emociones hay muchos estudios que ya
indican que en bebés que desde los 9
meses les ponen las pantallas empiezan a
no tener regulación por sí mismo un poco
más adelante y esto pues vendrán muchos
estudios más
el tiempo humano y la tecnología de hoy
el tiempo humano y el tiempo tecnológico
no son compatibles
el tiempo humano para poder crear
vínculos necesitamos tiempo espacio
disposición constancia para poder crear
vínculos amorosos que nos den salud
mental verdad en la tecnología todo es
totalmente inmediato o sea no existe
nada de esto por eso tantos adultos o
insatisfechos andan por la vida
sintiéndose mal porque no tienen esa
gratificación inmediata que es lo que
brinda la tecnología pero necesitamos
todo este proceso de vida para poder que
se cree en el niño entonces esto es algo
que debemos pensar muy bien para que en
el día de hoy poder abrir estos espacios
poder llegar más interacción y no
dejarnos absorber tanto por la
tecnología
el amor debe ser experimentado con los
sentidos el amor debe ser sentido en la
piel todo esto va quedando en nuestra
mente y después vamos buscando estas
mismas experiencias una y otra vez el
niño necesita poder calmarse con la voz
de la madre con el toque de la piel no
en la pantalla allí estamos entonces
teniendo un déficit muy grande podríamos
pensar entonces que en una relación sana
se deben poder integrar estos aspectos
positivos y aspectos negativos de los
que hemos estado hablando tanto el amor
como los aspectos negativos deben poder
ser integrados dentro de las relaciones
relación cualquiera entre esposo esposa
madre e hijo hermanos deben poder
contener las relaciones las efectos los
afectos negativos deben poder ser
contenidos dentro de las relaciones para
que entonces sean relaciones que nos
ayuden a crecer los desacuerdos siempre
van
y deben haber desacuerdos para poder
ayudar a los otros a entenderlo ya tener
una mente propia entre uno y el otro y
permitirlo entonces esta integración es
muy importante porque es lo que nos
ayuda a tener relaciones más maduras el
poder integrar los aspectos buenos y
malos es madurez y es lo que fomenta la
madurez emocional
entonces para poder
buscar tener vínculos más sanos es
importante poder conocer nuestra
historia reconocerla reconocer aquellas
cosas buenas y malas aspectos negativos
y positivos que existieron para no
repetirlas trabajamos mucho con familias
que al ir viendo y entendiendo sus
dinámicas pueden irlas modificando y
ayudando a sus miembros a tener mayor
salud mental mientras que otros cuando
las siguen repitiendo y repitiendo
entonces provocan
más enfermedad es muy importante
entonces poder separar estos espacios y
poder brindar entonces relaciones en las
que tengamos interacción para poder
entonces que sea el amor lo que nos
mueva y tener relaciones donde podamos
vivir y crecer mucho mejor
[Aplausos]